Speaker 1: We are going to look today at
one of the most remarkable pieces of video
that I have ever seen in the entire time I
have been doing this show. And you all know,
we've seen a lot of outrageous video in the middle
of Alex Jones defamation trial. It is the award
phase during which a jury is to decide how much
money should the plaintiffs get for having been
defamed by Infowars conspiracy theorist Alex
Jones. It was revealed that Alex Jones own
incompetent lawyer sent a digital copy of all of
Alex Jones text messages and phone communications
to the plaintiffs lawyers. I really need people
to understand how insane this is. Alex Jones For
the last ten, 12, 14 days, however long this phase
of the trial has been going on, has been lying and
making claims like I never did any texting about
Sandy Hook, which is the subject matter of the
defamation trial. And all along, the plaintiff's
counsel had knowledge that Alex Jones was lying.
He did text about Sandy Hook and the reason the
lawyer knew it is Alex Jones lawyer mistakenly
sent him all of the records. And yesterday during
the trial, it came out this video going instantly
viral. Do you know what perjury is becoming
the line of the day? You have to see this.
Speaker 3: So you did get my text
messages. Said you didn't. Nice trick.
Speaker 4: Yes, Mr. Jones, indeed.
Speaker 1: Yes, Mr. Jones, indeed.
Speaker 4: He didn't give this text message to
you. Don't you don't know where this came from.
Do you know where I got this? No. Mr. Jones,
did you know that 12 days ago, 12 days ago,
your attorneys messed up and sent me an
entire digital copy of your entire cell phone
with every text message you sent. For the
past two years and when informed, did not
take any steps to identify it as privileged or
protected in any way. And as of two days ago,
it felt free and clear into my possession.
Speaker 1: This is this is one of the best things
that has ever happened during a trial I've seen.
Speaker 4: That is how I know you lied to me when
you said you didn't have text messages about you.
Speaker 1: And this is the moment that Alex Jones
soul leaves his body. You can see it
exit at the 47/2 mark in this video.
Speaker 4: Did you know that?
Speaker 3: I'm sorry. I told you the truth. This
is your Perry Mason moment. I gave them my phone.
Speaker 5: And then Mr. Jones. You mean to answer
the question?
Speaker 3:
No. Know. I don't know what happened, but, I mean,
I told you. I gave him a phone over the just.
Speaker 4: You said you said in your deposition.
You searched your phone, you said you pulled down
the text. Did the search function for Sandy
Hook? That's what you said, Mr. Jones Correct.
Speaker 3: And I had several, several
different phones with this number, but I did.
Yeah, of course. I mean, that's why you got it.
Speaker 1: The pretzel that Alex Jones is twisting
himself into is really something else here.
Speaker 4: Now, Mr. Jones, that's not why.
Speaker 3: My lawyers say to
you, but I'm hiding it. Okay.
Speaker 5: Mr. Jones.
Speaker 4: For Mr. Jones, I.
Speaker 5: Just answered
questions. There's no question Mr.
Banks can also only ask questions, sir.
Speaker 4: Mr. Jones, in discovery you were asked,
do you have seen your text messages on
your phone and you said No. Correct.
You said that under oath that Senator.
Speaker 3: Obama was mistaken. I was
mistaken. But you've got two messages right there.
Speaker 4: You know, perjury. I want to make sure,
you know, before you go any
further. You know what it is?
Speaker 3: Yes, I do. I mean, I'm not a tech
guy. I told you, I gave it my testimony on the
phone to the lawyers before or whatever. And so
you got my phone, but we didn't give it to you.
Speaker 4: Mr. Johnson, one more time. Please
remember, you need to search for the memory card.
I mean, I know you can't do that, but you test me.
Speaker 1: If you need to plead the fifth year,
then you're able to do that. Which, of
course, I mean, it's a strategy as well,
because that if all of a sudden he asserts
the Fifth Amendment, even though, of course,
strictly speaking, that cannot be used in
order to indicate guilt or responsibility,
it's certainly not going to look very good.
I have no idea how. Plaintiff's counsel.
Did not. I don't know how plaintiff's counsel
was able to go two weeks without the biggest
sitting grin on his face, as Alex Jones tells
lie after lie, knowing that he has the records
already. He waited until the perfect moment and
he dropped it like he had been planning this his
entire life. It's very difficult to imagine a
more humiliating and public implosion than this.
And then also during during yesterday's testimony,
Alex Jones was confronted about the fact that
during the trial, he's been broadcasting
images of the judge on fire. And that's also
just another incredible moment. Look at this.
Speaker 4: Can you just play? The person on the
left in this image, Sir Josh? Correct?
Speaker 3: Yes.
Speaker 4: The person on the right
is another judge you don't like.
Speaker 3: Right? Yes. Okay.
Speaker 4:
One of the things you think about, one of the
things you've been talking about a lot recently
on your show, even within the past couple months,
is your allegation that government officials
are aiding in pedophilia, child
trafficking and the grooming of children?
Speaker 1: He's basically being confronted
with Pizzagate as applied to the judge
in a court of law while under oath.
Speaker 3:
What do you mean? Like what Jeffrey Epstein did?
Speaker 4: Sure. If that's a yes. Yes.
Speaker 3: Yes.
Speaker 4: Okay. And on Thursday,
you and Infowars started connecting
those allegations to our judge who didn't
know. In fact, Mr. Jones, you're telling the world
not to believe what happens in this courtroom,
because the judge worked with Child Protective
Services, who you say is involved with pedophilia
and child trafficking. Correct.
Speaker 3: Not all of it. The
Texas Youth Commission got caught doing
it a lot different. A lot of that here.
Speaker 4: I'm not asking you
that, Mr. Jones. I'm asking you.
Speaker 1: You're telling imagine if every time
these right wing nuts lied, they were subjected
to under oath cross-examination of their
claims. I mean, Trump would have no campaign.
Speaker 4: Moral not to believe
what's happened in this trial,
because this judge is involved with CPS who is
working with child traffickers in pedophilia.
Speaker 1: Correct. By the way, if you're
not watching the look on the judge's face
as Alex Jones is being questioned
about his claims about this very judge,
I have never seen anything like this.
Speaker 3: No, that's not what I'm saying.
Speaker 4: Your Honor, at this time, we
would like to show up for Mr. Jones show
on Thursday, where those words are said.
Speaker 5: For impeachment for different.
Speaker 4: Purposes. Yes, Your Honor.
Speaker 1: All right. So now they get into,
you know, Alex Jones lawyer tries to exclude the
video that they want to play and ultimately they
do play it. This is unlike anything I have ever
seen. A massive public humiliation for Alex Jones.
And in this next segment, we are going to look at
when the subject of the money finally comes up.